all right bring out the uh what else is
in my box
what else am i going i'm i'm just gonna
keep bringing that [ __ ] out so the other
challenge i had was to buy a wall scroll
so uh i just bought a hog show
do you even need to see it no no okay no
one cares i like your
i mean like my challenges were to i mean
one of them was this and one of them was
that so that's both of my challenges
because the next challenge was to uh
squat anytime i saw every zero figure
and i really regret not going to the gym
because my [ __ ] god that burnt the
next day i'm not even joking right
because now that i've moved into a house
with stairs
just going up to my bedroom hurts
i'm just like i just after that i just
bought figures that i liked
oh i wanted to get that got his county
figure i wanted to get that so bad um
just because i i've never seen a fully
cooling represent boys yeah exactly
that's the blue candy too yeah yeah i
have a red candy at home actually
hell yeah so i mean i'm glad that
they're still making fully cooling
figures are they still is this new
because i didn't know this was all
right isn't everything at army army like
relatively new i think this is from the
second hand
um is it from the second hand section
yeah it's from the second hand right um
yes literally says 1990.
no no that's when it came out oh okay
okay okay
yeah so uh that's that nice uh ashley
can you get me the the lamp
yeah this is something that i was gonna
buy yeah so connor saw me reaching out
for this and i thought it was too cool
not to get yeah i wanted to get this for
myself for the longest time but i got a
majora's mark it's not a figure but i
thought it looked cool in the studio
it's a majora's mask
light up statue yeah sydney actually
went back to amiyami and bought this oh
really like two days after it's pretty
sick it is really good that looks that
would look amazing you can hand it off
to them they can get it oh yeah good
idea
sorry
[Laughter]
wow
it's all jubilee too yeah i don't know
why i didn't think of jubilee yeah i
don't know why i just wanted to either
uh one two like when i when i i remember
the challenge of anime only movies and i
was like oh man how many hosoda things
are there no because i was just like how
many shinkai figures i was like
that's uh that's an anime only akira
jerry's gonna i figured it would be
whoever got the most because it was the
most anime figures yeah sorry i thought
i got mistake i thought it was the most
expensive no no no so i bought six
from ghibli all right well you've got
you've got that point
you've got that point but do you have a
majora's mask lamp i don't think so but
i have um
this is sick though like you can
actually put food in it and it'll like
chomp it and spit it out
what do you need that for i don't know i
just thought it was it was cool to have
no face figure that can chomp and spit
[ __ ] fair enough no yeah i guess uh the
fire from house that's cute right
calcifer i think um
yeah
yeah you can see you can hear you can
hear it nabi um cheering because is it
yes
this is the only thing that gets now be
excited it's oxton because she's okay
it's it's okay to alter the [ __ ] is this
what is this it's okay someone's the
best looking fate some sometimes you
roll for a character and uh you are
unfortunately oh it's from fate yeah
yeah yeah later
it talks to alter those the best
character honestly this this is like in
terms of like her ranking in terms of
gameplay it's like it's it's not the
best but in terms of [ __ ] design holy
[ __ ] this is one of my favorite designs
i agree and if you bought this you would
have got a point joey because i don't
own her i tried tried rolling for her
did not get her um well
we'll find out about that later that was
in monroe i was in monday yeah and
that's and that's why you know if you
can't if sometimes you roll for a gacha
and you don't get it so sometimes you go
out your way and you own them physically
and that's uh that's what i did okay
okay so my biggest challenge at army
army was to get a figure of a character
that is american
okay now i had to double check here
right
it didn't say anime character it just
said character right because admittedly
there isn't a whole lot of american
anime characters there's a few there's a
few like that guy from yugioh yeah
there's a few but definitely not
famous enough to make a figure out of
yeah right but luckily i i checked with
the staff and i said okay does it
necessarily have to be anime it doesn't
say it needs to be anime so as long as
it's an american and you guys have no
problems with it being an american then
i thought it was okay right so i got
probably one of the most american people
ever
lebron james
why is there a lebron james absolutely
what american you can't argue it's a
figure
i'll i'll give you that i'll give you
that i'll give you that too
representative
we have we have a lebron james figure in
the studio
applause ladies and gentlemen why the
[ __ ] is there a lebron if if lebron
james can appear in space jam he can
appear on trash taste okay he's
technically an anime character he was in
space
you can make him dunk you can make him
do the finger thing as well it's great i
love this
okay cool actually yeah that is pretty
cool i'm gonna take him out actually
yeah um do you have any more figures
connor uh yeah a few four four more four
more um
i i think i only have one more right i
think i only have one more i don't have
a few more but do you want to take some
more out
really
thanks [ __ ]
yes
you know what you know what guys i was
this close to buying one as well i was
this close oh
no at least the reason that's what your
price was because i was like at least
let me be mine cheaper and it was
cheaper so [ __ ] you you overpaid by 20
bucks that's all right i'm gonna take
one of these home
all right two points off i guess because
we're idiots two
so one of my challenges was to buy a
male character and this was it why that
one you could have gone for any other
male character there's a reason why joey
okay because
i also bought something else to go along
with it okay
oh you bought the motorbike oh you
bought the motorbike i'm so glad you
bought that i know because i saw it and
i was like
i don't know because it's not going to
give me any points or anything but oh
there's alter okay
look at that octa ultra dude
damn
goddamn oh it is easily the best looking
fake character i'm sad now that i don't
own her this this is this is making me
so sad i now know that you don't own her
so this is the bike and yeah it's a big
box yeah i bought this because i well i
was going to buy this because it was
hundred dollars
and i thought at the time i'm i'm like i
was very confident at the time that it
was the most expensive figure i don't
know if you guys bought another one yeah
i still you know from all the stores so
far i think it is i think so far
yesterday so the reason why i bought the
other figure was to try and secure the
challenge of spending the most on one
series yeah how much how much was this
bike
600 600
oh my god it's like a whole mic it's
like a full-on operation oh my god look
at that this is not a podcast episode
anymore this is just an unboxing yeah
i like how we've just made a glorified
unboxing episode and uh audio aliens are
going to be so confused yeah if you're
watching if you if you come this far oh
lord
so cool
yo i can only get so erect dog
holy [ __ ] that's amazing oh it moves
holy [ __ ] that is so cool holy [ __ ] i
hope you can [ __ ] put it
on the set
yeah that's like canada
i hope i hope you can put canada on that
god damn that looks good that is so cool
again that's not that that supersedes a
figure i think that's yeah that's just a
statue
dude i really hope you can get him to
sit on it so the main so the main reason
i wanted to get it was because i was
near certain that yeah it did indeed
yeah
i mean that's impressive but look at my
boiler
clean
look at that physique that perfect
physique oh look at that look at that
that's so cool so i wonder why it
doesn't really stand up very well i
think in even in the
the movie it kind of leans when it
stands yeah but like it's like that i
think i think he needs to stand on the
side right the boy's a low rider yeah
and the set though i thought that would
look sick behind us yeah having you know
a one to sixth scale of the bike i just
thought you can't say no to that yeah
that that's sick you know what that
legitimately looks amazing yeah uh worth
wasting two points for um
so yeah i agree you know what i ain't
even mad i lost two points because we
got that yeah we got that in the [ __ ]
set yeah right right right isn't this
[ __ ] sick right all right everybody
move way for lebron james
he's like hi
it's me lebron